so 4:23 we are the flash this season
finale to the bow has set off the
satellites the Enlightenment is enacted
they have about an hour before
everybody's brain is rebooted Cisco we
need power working on it
nothing's working not even cell phones
team flash has no options they don't
know what to do until Marlies de bois is
brought to them by iris West and very
well and now I'm gonna ask you what are
you willing to do for the world
marlise of all people has a crazy idea
the only way that they can stop him is
to go into the thinker's mind
I love Inception as much as the next guy
but sending Barry into Devoe's mind
everything is turned on its head once
Barry gets in there and realizes exactly
how the thinker's mind works
hey everybody its Charlie so we got to
talk about new flash footage and we have
our first official look at the Shazam
costume that Zachary Levi was wearing
and all those behind-the-scenes pictures
that were dropping earlier this year so
we'll do flash footage first I'll talk
about the finale about mystery girl
about what's happening with season five
that we know about so far including that
Batwoman crossover then I'll talk about
Shazam because it's the finale there's a
new round of that flash ring giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video but the producers gave us a couple
confirmations about what's going on when
Barry is fighting the thinker Marley's
is the one that comes with the idea to
try and inception DeVoe a lot of you
been asking about Ralph potentially
getting his body back because that's the
last body that the thinker took so he's
walking around in Ralph's body but he's
using Ralph's powers to make himself
look like the classic DeVoe version of
the thinker remember during Inception
where they would go to different layers
of people's minds and they would
interact with that person like if they
were trying to infiltrate someone's mind
you could actually talk to them but it
got a little bit weirder as they would
inception multiple times into multiple
layers now as far as we know Barry's
just going into one layer of Debo's mind
there are 12 metas total that are inside
to vote so I'll be really interested to
see if he tries to do the multiple
inceptions thing where he goes multiple
layers deep inside teuvos mind the
writers on the TV show had been kind of
ambiguous about what happens to a
person's consciousness after a devote
takes their abilities and then
transports himself into another person's
body is their version of black bison in
there is there a version of Becky or any
of the other metas besides Ralph
I think Ralph is the one that we're
talking about just because he's the
biggest character and most of the season
was dedicated to his art that's why
people were like how come the season
wasn't about berry because it was mostly
about berry training elongated man going
from douche bag to hero right now the
real conversation is is what are they
gonna do to set up mystery girl for a
next season because Candice Patton
herself tweeted this out specifying
exactly what they would be leaving for
next season we found out at the end of
episode 20 that she doesn't seem like
she's really happy about iris not only
does she want to avoid iris catching her
she also doesn't seem really happy about
her either
so she takes off but back in episode 8
during the crossover on Supergirl she
was really happy to meet Barry like that
was the best thing that she could have
possibly done total stranger never seen
me before so seemingly there are members
of team flash that she really likes and
their members that she doesn't like so
much so I could come up with a bunch of
different reasons why she might not like
Iris even if she does wind up being
related to her like this is iris his
daughter why would she be mad at her
mother and to get you even more hyped up
they did drop a couple of season five
bombs so this is the quote that they
pulled from Grant Gustin there will be
two cliffhangers at the end of the
season one which Grant Gustin says will
be one of the most exciting that the
show has ever done while the other one
is one of the most dark and confusing
that the show has ever done he clarified
that when he said dark and confusing
what he means is is that it will change
the way you think about the flash like
what does this mean for the mythology of
the flash so the dark and confusing
teaser sounds like it's going to be what
their main arc is of the season the
actual over storyline then the other one
is probably the reveal that their
children eventually do get flash powers
and go on to have adventures so I will
say you know it probably is connected to
mystery girl in the finale and Cecile's
baby this dark and confusing future for
the flash team I wouldn't be surprised
if it's a very family centric story
there's a number of ways they could take
that I've already talked a little bit
about rumors of potential villains so
we'll wait for the finale to actually
nail some of those details down because
based on what they're saying we will
actually get those full-blown teasers
we'll be able to decode them with
reasonable doubt like okay reasonably
certain about which one or two
characters or storylines that they will
be adapting from the comics so they
might wind up doing the same thing that
arrow did with the way it wrapped up its
finale like arrow didn't end with a
whole lot of cliffhangers you knew
exactly what was going to be happening
in the first episode next season you
know who the villains are gonna be you
know where all the heroes are gonna be
so they might do the same thing with the
flash so we got to talk about that
Shazam costume now if you guys didn't
see Zachary Levi posted this its
promotional material so like this is
stuff that will go on billboards stuff
that'll be used in tie-ins they do with
big chains so what it looks like they're
doing is is they're really leaning into
the Tom Hanks big of it all we're
a little kid in an adult's body with at
least in the comics someone with power
on the scale of Superman now we know
this is connected to the events of
Justice League and the DC movies that
have come before because they said that
they'd be shooting inside a toy store
during the movie and they have this big
spread these are all the toys that
appear in the store during the movie
some of you may know that we've been
filming this movie Shazam here in
Toronto for many months now we even shot
a scene in a toy store and what you're
seeing here is a tip of the iceberg of
all of the incredible toys that were
there in that set and because we aren't
gonna be taking them with us we're gonna
be leaving them here with you and some
of these are Justice League toys that
were sold in real life when they were
promoting the movie last year so that
gives you an idea of the timeline like
this is happening
not too long after the events of Justice
League Superman has probably been back
and been doing his Clark Kent thing just
things are relatively normal in dr.
sivana is going to be the villain of the
movie so we don't really know how
powerful these characters will be
compared to the classic justice leaguers
are people like Wonder Woman
so like Wonder Woman is a full-blown
demigod so you just have a pretty good
idea of power scaling but technically
Superman is still supposed to be the
most powerful person so I'm guessing
that this version of Shazam is a little
less powerful but remember Superman is
vulnerable to magic so there's ways of
balancing those characters which will be
really interesting once we get to the
rocks Black Adam character who is still
supposedly going to be appearing
sometime in the next couple of years but
the artwork gives you a pretty good idea
for what his muscles are gonna look like
but it looks like it's based on what the
finished special effects will look like
when he's running around inside the
actual film they only just finished a
little while ago and this is what the
suit looked like in all the
behind-the-scenes videos so people are
like does he have a muscle suit on
underneath this suit is this what its
gonna look like in the actual film so
look at this next to this and you can
kind of see the difference the robots
are gonna be using a little bit of
Photoshop to tune this up as you would
expect but if Marvel can put a
convincing fake hulk in a trailer then I
think they could probably do wonders
with this CG the only real big Comic Con
teaser I'm expecting is gonna be for the
Aquaman movie they'll probably hype up
the Wonder Woman movie a little bit but
I wouldn't be surprised if they tease
more Superman can
inside the Shazam movie so just because
Aquaman is the only real big DC movie
coming out this year doesn't mean that
that's gonna be the only movie that they
hype up but I think we're just gonna
need to see some footage of this just to
get a sense for what it actually looks
like this gives you kind of an idea but
it's kind of hard to tell like sometimes
you just don't know till you actually
see that trailer
so let me know what you guys think were
you just gonna wait to see a trailer
until you pass judgment well like I said
there's a new round of that giveaway
going on on in the winter when I post my
episode video tomorrow so look out for
that there'll be a more Marvel posting
soon leave all your requests in the
comments below click here for my other
mystery girl finale video and click here
to learn about Jake Gyllenhaal Mysterio
in the spider-man sequel thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
you